n'as tu nous je ne pouvais pas quitter
le loir et cher sans aller à vouloir
rencontrer celles qui arrivent et le
paralympiques au plus haut
marie-amélie le fur est devenue
aujourd'hui la présidente du comité
paralympique et sportif français
rencontre avec une légende du centre val
de loire
l'athlète handisport marie-amélie le fur
a décidé de se lancer une nouvelle fois
dans l'arène des jeux paralympiques pour
la quatrième fois elle va tenter comme à
son habitude depuis dix ans de revenir
avec une médaille paralympique que
fait-elle en ce moment pour y arriver
eh bien je vais la rejoindre à blois
dans sa salle de sport
[Musique]
tout va bien ma réhabilite va bien
bonjour ça va bien oui merci de
m'accueillir en tout cas ici à blois
est-ce que vous abordez ces jeux
paralympiques différemment des
précédents forcément forcément on aborde
ses quatrièmes jeux différemment surtout
quand ce seront les derniers jeux aya il
ya une émotion toute particulière toute
singulière le contexte sanitaire nous
amène aussi à penser ces jeux
différemment pour la première fois en
plus de quinze ans de carrière je serai
loin de ma famille loin de mes proches
et gagner une médaille loin d'eux je
sais pas ce que ça fait et surtout j'ai
envie pour pour la fin de ma carrière
que ces jeux il est une émotion
particulière et surtout l'émotion du
partage de la rencontre de la
transmission c'est ce qui m'a manqué à
rio et j'espère véritablement pouvoir
voilà être dans cette notion de la
transmission à la jeunesse et à la
génération de 1024 à dubaï vous avez
atteint les 6 m 15
je crois c'est le challenge que vous
allez devoir et bien encore dépasser
pour ces jeux paralympiques de tokyo
faire six mètres
15 c'est un signal très positif c'est un
signal qui m'a permis aussi de retrouver
confiance en moi à un moment où j'avais
beaucoup de questions beaucoup de doutes
et finalement ça a vraiment redynamiser
ma préparation ça m'a remis en confiance
dans dans les objectifs et ça a permis
très rapidement qu'on puisse repartir
sur un bloc de de travail de fatigue
pour aller chercher un seul et unique
pic de forme cet été et le titre
paralympique vous mettez tout en offrant
ce moment justement pour dépasser ses
six mètres 15 mai on essaie en fait de
trouver des petits détails qui vont
permettre d'aller chercher ces 15
centimètres plus complémentaires parce
qu'à la fois 15 cm c'est pas grand chose
mais aussi c'est aussi beaucoup
donc on essaie en fait d'optimiser comme
ça plusieurs leviers plusieurs
indicateurs de la performance de trouver
aussi le
la bonne prothèses de la bonne lame le
bon réglage pour véritablement se
rapprocher petit à petit dans cette
saison des six mètres
alors cette année aussi il ya une grande
nouveauté puisque vous allez partir en
équipe
fusionner si je peux m'exprimer ainsi
avec à la fois et bien les olympiques et
les paralympiques sous une seule et même
étiquette de l'équipe de france c'est
aussi une nouvelle bannière finalement
de changer le regard en fait sur
l'inclusion des personnes en situation
de handicap
on est unis au travers des valeurs du
sport on est unis au travers des valeurs
des jeux que l'on fasse les jeux
olympiques ou les jeux paralympiques
il faut maintenant que ça se traduise
aussi dans la communication et dans les
médias